this is a facility for your mutants like
yourself
new things first got their powers
chances are they heard someone I know
you're scared but you're safe now
I don't think this is hospital
he's there what's the last thing you
remember Danny he said we had to route
the reason you survived it's because
you're a very uncommon girl you're not
not anymore do you know a mutants or
would anyone like to shared their first
time brain I was 13 I thought it was a
dream but just lost control
so I started panicking people got hurt
Roberto my girlfriend and partner
Giuliana
I killed 18 men one by one
[Music]
this isn't a hospital it's a cage
it's important we find out your collar
so we can help you get better I saw
something
I don't think she wanted me to see
[Music]
I don't think we're here to cut better
this place takes your grade it's for
year it may sir live through it until it
kills you he's there we can get out of
this together
[Music]
welcome back everyone it's Charlie this
is gonna be my New Mutants trailer video
they just dropped some new footage so
we'll break it down there's a whole
bunch of x-men and Marvel Easter eggs if
you're new to the channel be sure to
subscribe to get all the videos we're
doing a movie take a giveaway all you
have to do to enter is be a subscriber
and let me know what you want them to do
with x-men inside the MCU I know there's
a lot of questions about what's going on
with these characters because this film
was made at Fox before the big Disney
buy out but now technically it's being
released by Disney through their Fox
brand so how does this relate to MCU
mutant stuff what's going on with x-men
inside the MCU the movie itself was
actually made 3 years ago if you can
believe it it's been sitting on a shelf
since they finished a long time ago just
because of the Fox Disney buyout and
they weren't sure what they were gonna
do with the movie but for the most part
the movie is being described as a rubber
reality supernatural horror movie where
the characters in the movie aren't aware
of what the true nature of reality is it
seems different from their perceptions
so think Total Recall The Truman Show
the matrix demon bear has been confirmed
to be the main villain to this they're
doing the story from the demon bear saga
which is basically the first big story
of the new mutants comic book when it
first debuted a lot of that comes
through Danny moon stars character she's
the character that's been opening most
of these trailers with Celia Reyes the
seeming nurse ratchet of this equation
talking to her Dino mutants are the
movie itself is obviously the story of
the new mutants team meeting each other
for the first time originally it was
planned to be a trilogy Josh Boone the
director said that he pitched a trilogy
to Fox that they had intended on making
depending on how successful this first
movie was but that was before the big
Disney Fox buyout deal the imagery of
this hospital of the third and I was
obviously meant to make you think of an
insane asylum but later in the trailer
there's that moment where Ileana is like
wake up people this is a prison sort of
waking them up to the fact that this
isn't the reality that they think it is
pushing on those boundaries is if it's
some sort of nightmarish dream that
they're trapped in that gets into a
little bit of demon bears powers I'll
talk about that in a second because
obviously I think a lot of people have
figured out the twist of this movie or
at least one of the twists in the fact
that this is not real this place that
they're in you see all these tropes of
monsters seemingly trying to push
through the walls attacking them strange
creatures appearing out of
know where some of the boundaries of
this reality seemingly collapsing and
then demon bear himself manifesting in
really crazy supernatural ways I'm
getting out of Friday the 13th Freddy
Krueger vibes as in there trapped in a
mine space so technically it's not the
physical world so their powers don't
work the way that they think they do in
demon bears controlling this reality if
you haven't read any of the demon bear
saga or you're not familiar with the New
Mutants though he's basically
responsible for killing Danny Moon stars
parents and he's coming for her next so
she's the link to demon bear like you
see all these seemingly flashback scenes
to an accident where maybe her family
winds up dying and then she's sitting in
the hospital as if the memory is
bleeding into her present day so that
just sounds like it's demon bear
manipulating her abilities trying to
slowly corrupt their souls and then
consume them that's sort of his thing
going around consuming people so during
the footage when they say I think I saw
something she didn't want me to see it
also sounds like maybe demon bear is
manipulating Celia Reyes if she's a real
character in the movie - or if she's
just a manifestation the demon bear is
projecting she is based on a real comic
book character but it's kind of hard to
tell with the way they're playing this
supernatural reality like is this place
real is what you're experiencing real or
is this all happening inside your mind
or inside someone else's mind you on
amazing Williams is playing Reince and
Claire aka Wolfsbane a character that
turns into a werewolf like she talks
during this they all sort of narrate
their backstories like I don't really
know what's happening but I know
something weird happened to me as my
powers manifested usually in some crazy
violent way they're playing this a
little bit darker because it's a pseudo
horror film
I wouldn't say full blown horror but
it's as bad as close to a horror film as
we've gotten even though they're teasing
horror elements during Doctor Strange -
you all probably recognize Charley
Heaton from stranger things as cannon
ball he can propel himself through the
air becoming invulnerable kind of
turning himself into a cannon ball of
sorts even if you don't recognize this
actor the character he's playing is
actually pretty important this is
Roberto decosta aka sunspot he's
important for a couple different reasons
I mean he has a really cool power he
basically manipulates solar energy like
you could see him use his power here but
when I say this movie was originally
planned to be the first movie in a
trilogy his father was actually part of
the health
clubs inner circle so that's why I think
that the Hellfire Club and larger x-men
stuff was going to be happening in these
sequels but a lot of those plans have
changed since the Disney buyout also
there was the rumored mr. sinister post
credit scene where first Jon Hamm was
supposed to show up at the end of the
movie as mr. sinister and then Antonio
Banderas supposedly filmed some scenes
for the end of the movie
so either Antonio Banderas at one time
was a version of mr. sinister they may
have canceled that but they could always
bring him back as Roberto de castas
father if they want to do sequels to
this the funny thing too is is because
we know Deadpool is coming to the MCU
the next connection to all this
tangential Deadpool MCU stuff is on a
Taylor Joyce Illyana Rasputin character
aka Aidan magic probably one of the
coolest characters in this trailer you
see her manifest her magical armor she's
one of the first people that seems like
they realized that this is not real the
stuff that they're experiencing at this
hospital this is fake were being trapped
in a prison she's the sister of Colossus
in the comics so we have Colossus inside
the Deadpool movies but we also have
other versions of Colossus that have
been in the other x-men films even
though I think they're gonna recast a
lot of x-men characters the Deadpool
characters actually seem like they're
safe so this does really well and people
really like her and Kevin Feige likes
her as this character he could always
bring her back inside future Deadpool
sequels but there's a big question about
what's going on with the future of the
Disney Plus Series I do think eventually
there will be some smaller scale x-men
Disney Plus stuff but it's gonna be
years before that happens for the most
part like I said this movie is all about
the team coming together and then the
sequel was going to be them becoming the
new mutants team formerly worrying about
as close to matching costumes as you
could get but based on what the director
said they weren't gonna take it to
mainstream x-men territory where they
walk around in formation all wearing
matching costumes all the time the funny
backstory on the movie too is that
originally you may have heard about some
weird reshoots that they had planned
that never happened well the thing was
is that originally this movie was
supposed to be a horror film Fox wanted
to make it more mainstream and water it
down with a bunch of reshoots then the
Fox Disney deal happened so they put the
film on a shelf just status pending so
the Disney could evaluate all the Fox
projects and decide which ones they
wanted
Hansol which ones they wanted to keep
making Kevin Feige actually approved the
movie as is said it's totally fine we
don't need any reshoots do it the way
that you wanted to do it so I think
that's a big vote of confidence for the
actual movie itself but it is meant to
be a much smaller type of film and I
think the fact that they didn't force it
to crossover with any of the x-men
apocalypse stuff or mainstream x-men
stuff is actually gonna be one of it's
saving graces
speaking of which big news we're gonna
get a Marvel Eternals trailer pretty
soon that'll probably drop with the
Black Widow movie we're also supposed to
get the venom 2 trailer really soon - I
believe they're gonna be dropping that
with the bloodshot movies sometime this
month so as soon as they release that of
course I will do a video there'll be all
kinds of Easter eggs keep our eyes
peeled for more spider-man crossover if
there was a ton of spider-man inside the
Morbius trailer you can bet that there's
gonna be a little bit of Spider Man
stuff going on inside the venom 2
trailer I know there were a lot of
rumors about x-men Wolverine stuff
happening inside the MCU I did a video
explaining what's going on with that
what the reality of the situation is so
I'll link that video at the end of this
but everyone let me know in the comments
what do you want them to do with these
characters if they bring them back
inside future MCU projects would you
rather see them in smaller Disney Plus
movies or would you rather wait to see
them a couple years down the road in a
bigger x-men movie everyone click here
for that new Wolverine MCU video and
click here for my big Marvel Eternals
teaser breakdown thank you so much for
watching everyone stay awesome I'll see
you guys tonight
[Music]